whoa he says that to everyone usually
people look dorky but you man hey put
the chin strap on whoa my man looking
Sharp
[Music]
the patient has died after a nurse
switches off the loud heart alarm while
she facetimes her family [__] dude
that's crazy
let's talk to your family one more time
and they FaceTime and then she's like
hits the button yeah like the heart
alarm why an 85 year old patient died
after a nurse switched off his heart
monitor while on FaceTime to her family
her name is Geraldine lumbo design a
Filipino oh God damn it [__] no a nurse
at the net chances are they're gonna be
Filipino Sydney she received the call
from her relatives during the the night
shift on July 29th
the nurse turned off the patient's alarm
while chatting with her family back oh
this is so loud hold on something's
beeping on a 66 Administration call so
her family from the Philippines is
calling her to Sydney she also failed to
inform doctors about the patient's
irregular heart rhythm an hour before he
died
and uh 66 minute phone call too yeah I
did make it shorter come on it's
International they don't possibly
talking about for that one also get some
get some airpods you know but you know
when you talk to your relatives they you
know they all they want you to switch
the phone to all 10 people in the room
and stuff yeah that's so she's probably
like
put Auntie on the phone yeah you make
make her aside more relatable yeah put
the point that's my brother with my my
nephew slash godson or whatever it's
like I don't need to see him playing
with his toys this isn't uh this isn't a
[__] conversation
kids just like hey hey Uncle Steve like
yeah look at my [__] train and I'm
like
yeah Steve as a father nothing warms
your heart more than when you show your
child to your friends and loved ones I
disagree
you're not a father though so you
wouldn't understand it too it's not my
kids exactly that's all you would never
understand you never understand like
when it's your good understand here me
and Bart oh why would you have a kid I
got two little ones dude I got two
little ones I got two little I got a boy
or girl and they're they're practically
are they still eating their own [__]
I mean I told you that they lick each
other's butts right because they watch
their mom and dad do it
yeah how do you uh how do you trade them
not to [__] each other
oh I have to keep them separated please
okay but that's just called responsible
parenting and you would never understand
did you give away the rest of their
siblings yet I did as of the good homes
bro as a father I want to divvy up my
children
and I take them for walks dude I feed
them treats okay just like me and just
like Martin wood would tuck sit take us
well on behalf of the Filipino Community
sorry if that happens
are you really sorry I think you should
say it again yeah I'm pissed because
Filipino is supposed to be really good
nurses yeah they are though but you know
people can make mistakes just in their
field if you make a mistake it just
might we can't afford any more mistakes
is is there a penalty for this she's
murdered uh yeah her registration was
suspended for at least 12 months at
least 12 months
and for like the heart monitor thing
gotta have at least like three buttons
till I turn it off right you know like
if you can't just open the the plane
door you gotta like this and then this
and then this for safeties yeah why do
you know that because I'm studying it
okay you can't just take this job
seriously man because I've been a leader
for the uh
you're the guy you're the guy is it loud
and like annoying though the heart
monitor thing is that why she started
off well it's like she couldn't go to
the different room it was an alarm it
wasn't like oh like it would kept going
off it was like the heart alarm because
something was irregular with it she goes
shut up
already shot's way more relatable like
the alarm only goes off with something
bad is happening so airpods fire alarm
she's like shut up a sound so only 12
months and then she's back she actually
murdered someone she was found guilty of
professional misconduct and
unsatisfactory professional conduct so
that's what they're calling it huh
that's that's a pretty big blender
and it says nursing and medical staff
could not hear the alarm because the
Telemetry alarm speakers were still
disconnected dude that's all sounds like
a Fontana Kaiser but I mean should she
be punished for being lazy
is laziness a crime yeah in this case
absolutely I want to see if somebody
dies I don't know if she's laser is just
[__] jaded yeah [__] that could be it
to be fair there's a lot of sounds that
come from freaking hospital equipment
that they just go it's not fine like
you're not you're okay you know it's
like when you have a CL when your alarm
goes off in the parking lot you don't
think someone's breaking in and you know
they are yeah you just hear the sound
you're like all right I'm like shut up
why can't FaceTime be like some
technology that old people hate but
instead it's always old people [__]
yeah that's true huh yes every time I
either text or like voice memo or like
if I really have to recall dude I'm at
the grocery store and I watch this guy
being so disrespectful to the checkout
person they're like FaceTiming their
[__] bro or whatever or this chick
and like the cashiers are trying to ring
them up and like have them pay and
they're just keep on [__] going and
going and going like this yeah if it's
all people that's not it's not selfie
angle it's like their whole nose is
covering the camera what there's also
like the even before that there was the
obnoxiously large Bluetooth yes I still
use that that's my dad yeah what a phone
clip for sure Bluetooth and full phone
now it's the airpods after I got them
airpods dude this guy when he found out
that you could just use one so that you
could save the battery of the other and
then when this dies you can switch it
they already last forever thanks dude
mine's done all the time what yeah you
know it was a top selling uh phone
accessory item in the early 2000s in
Cerritos Mall the wallets the leather
flip phone holster for your belt I had
it I had one too bro and I loved it
they're gangster I wish I could bring it
back we couldn't keep those on the show
the day that I said I can't do this
anymore was when I had my phone on the
belt clip thing and I was moving out
from from this shitty apartment and I
was got in this argument with my
girlfriend at the time and I told her to
go [__] off and stuff and then the door
for this apartment thing snap back and
hit the side of my and broke my phone I
couldn't like call her back and be like
hey I'm sorry I said go [__] yourself or
whatever like because it was my screen
was shot and I was like I couldn't call
her back and say sorry for saying go
[__] yourself the door broken I did the
door snapped back what kind of Vault was
it it was one of those um uh Treo 600s
that's such a don't let the door hit you
on the way out like truth
yeah it's bloody dude but if you could
apologize because she's listening right
now
I wouldn't now because we broke up this
isn't the one that you sat across from
the comedy bar no no okay
this is earlier than that yeah she was
being a real major flaming [__] and I
had to let her know
I did have one of those though I'm not
gonna lie yeah those are tight the trail
600s no the leather oh yeah yeah yeah
the holster for the flu with a magnetic
magnetic strip that would just like you
flip
so dorky but like such a top seller man
so good it matched my rolly backpack I
bet I knew it that I didn't have he also
probably dropped phones way less back
then because now it's like you're just
holding in your hand and you're keeping
your pocket it's probably sliding on
falling all over the place I wish you
got cracked screens every single phone I
had a crack screen yeah we need more
wallet I mean like belt cases
for the phone we should talk about
accessories maybe a wallet chain a chain
a bike chamber
I do like how my glasses have the
[__] cord in the back helps me
[Laughter]
I got a dorky hat recently
um it's like a it's kind of like a
fisherman's fly Fisherman's bucket hat
right that's as far as flaps on it yo it
has a [__] chin Safari flag it has a
[__] chin strap as hell right it's
normal though and it has the back neck
covering yeah see because it's like a
mullet you don't want you don't want
your uh it's good for sun though yeah UV
protection that's good for fishing those
are Safari flaps it's like the the
built-in do-rack yep it's my it's my
it's my paddle boarding I have one of
those from Colombia you need it did the
the guy at the store say he's never seen
anyone pull it off
everyone usually people look dorky but
you man looking good chief
that looks like a fit to me
holy [__] you pull that off man I didn't
whoa I never seen anybody pull that off
nobody pulls it off like you gotta get
this hat bro usually only losers wear
this but yeah how much is the Hat it's
150 but it's well worth the investment
but today is 175 for you hey put the
chin strap on whoa my man looking sharp
and the chin straps tight so it pushes
my face like this it makes my cheeks
[__] fat you got a sexy jawline with
that don't buy that hat I'm gay I'm
kidding I'm getting it last one
sold out for the entire Midwest and
Joe's like you think I should get it
he's like I don't know about the color
he's like he's we got all the colors
[Music]